what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with
green lantern yes we are and we are
covering the new 52 green lantern
vol 1 sinestro so in the war of the
green lanterns we basically ended with
sinestro becoming a green lantern which
is one of the crazy things because he
formed the sinestro core literally
a group designed to kill green lanterns
and he is now a green lantern so the
whole thing about this
is as soon as that happens the guardians
of the of the universe are just like
uh okay let's go ahead and go with this
gantt that's the only one who's against
it right just because of the fact that
while the other guardians see it as a
quote unquote chance of redemption
the reality is ganthet sees it as like
this guy tried to kill us
we literally had to give green lanterns
the ability to kill people in order to
keep these guys
from killing all the green lanterns but
it's one of those things where gantha's
kind of being overridden now
one of the things that also came out of
war the green lanterns is that ganfit
and his his
the idea that he kind of deviated from
the mission of the guardians of the
universe
ultimately resulted in him kind of being
considered an outlier right and so their
response was we will deal with you
accordingly
and that's exactly what happens here
right they essentially kind of band
together
and basically remove the emotional
element from him so he's strictly a
logical being right kind of
falling rank and file with the rest of
the of the guardians here now
switching over to hal jordan we saw that
how jordan had been discharged from the
green lantern corps he'd basically been
booted out
and sent back to earth without a green
lantern ring and so what this meant was
that going forward he's just
a guy nothing special about him
whatsoever right
and this kind of manifests itself in a
couple different ways one his landlord's
demanding three months of rent because
he's two months behind and you know
i mean pretty much all the superheroes
are broke except for batman that's one
of the things about the superheroes
right they don't really do it for money
i would right i would be like all right
guys i'm here to save the world but
uh i'm gonna need i wanna be payment and
i don't take personal checks
i would not be that guy i would not i
would not like force people to pay me
to save the world i would force
governments to do it so
here's the thing like what he ends up
witnessing is basically like an attack
or at least seems like an attack going
on in an apartment
literally across the street he jumps
from his balcony to this other apartment
comes flying through the window
only to find out that it's basically a
great big huge acting job right and so
ultimately he's arrested
and he's bailed out of jail by carol
ferris now the relationship between
carol ferris and how jordan was always
kind of off and on right it was always
one of these things where it was a
little bit murky
and it was a in a lot of ways this kind
of situation of
are they going to be able to kind of
pull it together right are they going to
be able to sort of get together and and
do their thing
a lot of you guys know the history if
you guys have been watching my videos on
green lantern
but in reality it's a chance for hal
jordan to kind of try to bring things
back
right to focus largely on himself and
carol and just kind of see what comes
next right because you know i mean
al jordan's always had a thing for but
for sinestro once he sent out as a green
lantern and to
really expected to kind of do what green
lanterns do the first place he heads to
is kuruga now
those are the guys who are kind of
catching up here kuruguru is extremely
significant for sinestro for a bunch of
different reasons one
because it's his home world it's his
equivalent of earth and two when he was
originally a green lantern the reason
why he was initially kicked out
and then ultimately became the yellow
lantern and then essentially created the
semestral core
is that he wanted to bring logic and
reason to kuruger
and basically become a dictator of it
right now a lot of it kind of made sense
right kruger up to that point was rife
with political discord
nothing was ever really getting done
everybody was you know seemingly kind of
out for themselves in different ways
and so kind of casting all that aside
and then basically conquering the world
brought order and structure to it so
depending on what stance you're on
it was actually better right i mean yeah
sure people lost that freedom but
i mean look what they did with it right
was their freedom really doing him any
favors in the first place and so
ultimately sinestro having been or
having had this discovered by the
guardians
was essentially taken and stripped of
his role as a green lantern
because he essentially betrayed the role
the green lanterns were supposed to
supposed to uphold right like yes you're
supposed to protect worlds
but you're also supposed to let them
like descend into chaos and madness
because of all the
political nonsense and so on right so
it's one of those weird things where
it's like
keep the worlds protected but if they
end up destroying themselves
let that happen too and so ultimately he
ended up forming the sinestro course
some time later
and that's where a lot of that stuff
happens the problem is that as soon as
he gets back here
he realizes that when he had initially
departed the sinestro corps
that he didn't necessarily leave as a
leader that he had kind of gone on the
whole mission with like blackest night
and brightest day and all that kind of
stuff that wore the green lanterns and
everything
and essentially charged the sinestro
corps with protecting kuruguru right
it's the one kill one planet he cares
about more than anything else
the problem is the sinestro corps
basically conquered it and subjugated
the people
and so they essentially betrayed the
will of of thal sinestro because
while he is kind of in in and of himself
uh at least fancied himself a dictator
he didn't really rule in a brutal
fashion right it was one of these things
where it was like
i actually want to see this planet
succeed i want to see good things come
out of it uh
so yeah i mean you know you can't make
it on but without breaking a few eggs
right
you can't have it both ways you can't
have like a perfect utopia
and then at the same time no sacrifices
or not losing anything in the process
and so
it's one of these things where he just
kind of takes it upon himself to one
take out one of the sinestro corps
members who discovers him
and then two create a plan to take his
planet back and so following that what
you end up with is a kind of dinner date
between hal jordan and uh and carol
affairs
and it's one of these interesting things
right because as they're kind of having
this conversation
even though the relationship has been on
and off again for quite some time hal
jordan is just kind of like okay so like
he starts talking to her and says look i
never thought i'd be doing this
but i need to ask you something and
she's like yeah
and then he says like will you co-sign
the new lease on my car
she's like what she gets mad because she
had talked herself or she convinced
herself
that hal jordan was gonna ask her to
marry him right so she kind of tricked
herself or
made up a story that she in turn
believed it's one of the weird things
about human beings right we're very
illogical
you know like we convince ourselves
something's gonna happen and then when
it doesn't happen we get mad like
who told you that was gonna happen right
like who convinced you of that
you did you literally set up your own
problem and so ultimately how's like i
mean do you think i was going to ask you
to marry me i mean i don't
we just kind of started hanging out
again like why would i do that i mean
just because you convinced yourself
doesn't mean you were right it just
means you convinced yourself
and so eventually like she just kind of
leaves him hanging he ends up getting
back to his apartment he's got an
eviction notice
and then here comes sinestro right and
cedestro's like if you ever want your
ring back you'll do
everything i say and so what follows
here is really interesting because
when it comes to the relationship
between thal sinestro and hal jordan
despite what sinestro says and a lot of
the disdain that he has for hal jordan
at the end of the day he respects him
immensely right even if he says he
doesn't
he does and the reason why is because
he's here right now like
hal jordan was literally the first
person he went to he could have gone to
guy gardner he could have gone to jon
stewart he could have gone to kyle
raynor
but instead he went to hal jordan and
it's hey man i need you to help me with
this now
initially hal jordan takes like huge
offense to the idea that thal sinestro
is still a green lantern
considering his history leading the
sinestro court killing green lanterns
different things like that
and so ultimately how's like take the
ring off right he immediately kind of
goes to charge sinestro
and cenestro is like look that's that's
this is not this is not gonna work man
and how jordan kind of makes this funny
comment you know he's like i'm not
afraid of you and thal senestro is like
as if that mattered right that's the
thing to know there are times when
you're facing an enemy it doesn't matter
if you're afraid of them or not
they're still gonna crush you right like
fear has nothing to do with it it's just
you're painfully outmatched and that's
what's going on here right hal jordan's
just a regular guy
you know rahu willpower doesn't do any
good if he doesn't have a green lantern
ring right
at that point it's just you know kind of
being a little bit foolish but
ultimately thousand estro fashions a
ring
seemingly out of nothing creates one of
his own of his own accord
and then gives it to hal jordan now
there's caveats here right when when the
ring is given to hal jordan
and how jordan becomes a green lantern
again that he immediately goes to attack
sinestro
only for us to find out what the ring
being created by sinestro there's huge
limitations here for example
sinestro can shut it off anytime he
wants to he's programmed the ring so
that hal jordan can't necessarily attack
him with it
different things along those lines so in
a lot of ways how jordan is beholden to
the will of thal sinestro and that's
literally what he says
you work for me right like you are you
are operating under my purview now
and so ultimately he's like if you if
you if we're going to do this there's a
few things you need to know
and so what ends up happening it's like
this this massive item you know massive
thing that comes crashing now which is
actually a member of the sinestro corps
that was chasing thou senestro but comes
crashing onto earth smashes through a
bridge
and basically damage the bridge and then
how jordan goes to intervene
and initially like like he saves a woman
and then like he saves a car
and then like thou sinestro shuts off
his ring you know and like literally
this girl is pummeling to her death and
he's like
this is your problem hal jordan you
never think big enough you think too
simple
right and so literally what sinestro
does is he uses this ring
and basically saves everybody on the
bridge all at one time
and forces hal jordan to look now this
is important because that was always the
biggest limitation of hal jordan he was
two dimensional right it's what made
kyle rayner such a such a great green
lantern or so interesting to fans
outside of hal jordan hal jordan made
boxing gloves or
giant wrenches or a great big huge fist
or like a shovel
he never did anything interesting with
his ring and that's really what sinestro
says like
you have this the greatest power in the
universe and people here call you a
superhero right like
they don't call you that because you've
done anything on any gigantic meaningful
scale
they do that because you save somebody
from being attacked by a mugger
or you stop bank robbers right like the
ring was not meant for you to be used
to stop somebody who's robbing somebody
else with a giant boxing glove
the ring was meant to be used on a more
grandiose scale
to do things to protect the world as a
whole to think
bigger than just this small time stuff
that you've been doing
and initially how jordan's kind of
response or or belief here
is that sinestro is trying to talk him
into like becoming a dictator
and so that shows like no it's just you
have to learn to think outside the box
hal jordan
you think too small you don't think big
enough and so ultimately he kind of
spills the beans on what's going on
that the sinestro core is taking control
of kruger and he needs hal jordan to
essentially help him help him you know
save his own world
and that's when how's kind of like okay
look like that's the thing but
understand like if we do this
like i need to go talk to carol ferris
i need to make things right with her and
sedestro's like that's ridiculous man
what's more important here right like
saving what you what passes for a
relationship between you and this girl
or literally saving an
entire world that's the thing you know
and it's kind of crazy because
sinestro kind of calls him out here and
he's like saving a world is far more
important right like
you say you believe in saving the lives
of the innocents you say you believe in
saving the lives of people who can't
stand up for themselves
yet when it comes down to it you're
gonna you're gonna choose making amends
to some woman that you've kind of had
relationships with over the years but
not really
and it's just a giant gaping wound that
you call this this kind of romantic
interest
instead of saving the lives of innocent
people so what's it going to be
are you going to be the guy who actually
saves lives or are you going to be this
guy who's just trying to look to get
with a chick
and ultimately how jordan's like okay
fine so he ends up going with sinestro
to basically go and save lives now one
of the things about this is that as they
get to kuruguru
sinestro's got a bit of a plan here and
one of the things that he did which is
actually kind of wild here one of the
things that he did
is that he created a kind of fail safe
in the the sinestro core central power
battery which is
if you introduce an actual green lantern
to it which is to say
the little charging lantern that they
have you'll basically destabilize it
it'll basically create a kind of
disruption field right and that'll lead
to the sinestro core rings basically
failing
and it's one of the funny things because
it's the last thing green lanterns would
have thought of
hey guys the sinestro core is running
amok they're literally killing green
lanterns everywhere we find them
i have a hunch maybe we should put one
of our lanterns inside the yellow
central power battery
and it'll shut it down right like no
green lantern is thinking of that right
no green lantern
that would never come to mind so it's
one of the best things to do and even by
how jordan's response it takes him by
surprise now even with that happening
they're kind of watching all this go
down right because thou sinestro is
going to kind of
run interference or sort of be the the
main distraction and then in turn how
jordan is expected to fly into the
central power battery
introduce the green lantern and
essentially shut down all the sinestro
core rings
and when that's happening they actually
see this young girl who's being
tormented
by one of the members of the sinestro
corps and thousand estros like
no we can't act right we cannot act
right now if we do they'll slaughter
them all
so sure you'll save a young girl at the
expense of dozens of other people right
like
this is one of those times hal jordan
when the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the few
and that's really the one of the biggest
failings of how jordan and really
superheroes as a whole right like
there are times when you just have to
sacrifice somebody
for the greater whole superheroes the
way their written kind of flies in the
face of that and says no you actually
can save
everybody but that's what makes villains
a lot more interesting is it's
but no you can't though i mean like it'd
be nice if you could but you can't
like and in the times that you cannot
what are you gonna do are you just gonna
go crashing in there foolhardy
and just sort of like save one person
and sacrifice dozens or are you gonna
sacrifice one
and save dozens and that's what this is
sacrifice one to save dozens of people
and so it's one of those funny things
because suddenly
cenestro just flies into the middle of
the whole thing
literally ignores everything he just
told hal jordan
and the reason why is because there's a
girl named arsona who's there
that's basically kind of interfering by
attacking one of the members of the
sinestro court and cedestro
recognizes her and immediately goes
intervening there right so hal jordan's
like okay i guess this is when we make
our move
so then he goes to fly in to uh to one
of the to the central power battery
but when he does it doesn't work right
like green lantern detected
disintegration process initiated and how
jordan is just kind of crushed right i
mean he's not really killed
right but like as far as he goes he's
like it doesn't work right it doesn't
work the way that it's supposed to
and so ultimately how jordan is
basically captured by the members of the
cenestro corps
and so is sinestro himself and so it's
kind of crazy because ultimately how
jordan is taken
to a kind of to a location where
basically his power will just kind of
drain off
mostly because he'll use it to try to
get out but there's no real way for him
to escape and as we know
green lantern rings only have a finite
charge they have to recharge them on a
regular
but being separated from sinestro's
lantern there's no real way for hal
jordan to do that not only that
the ring he has is not as powerful as a
ring normally is
and so the energy drains off even faster
than that and so one of the last things
he does is kind of conjure an image of
carol ferris
kind of apologize to it as a way to sort
of soothe his guilty conscience
and then his ring energy fades away as
far as sinestro goes he's being tortured
by his own core
now there are some who are kind of
looking at this from the perspective of
maybe he's being manipulated by the
guardians maybe how jordan's controlling
him
but no way thou sinestro would turn
against his own court others are like it
was only a matter of time right like
we could never really have allegiance to
thal sinestro because look at his
history
he has no allegiance to anybody but
himself but regardless
thou sinestro is thrown in a kind of
prison room with everybody else who is
basically captured by the sinestro corps
including this girl and so as they have
this kind of conversation we end up
realizing
that for arsona what ended up happening
is that when thal sinestro initially
started rising to power
she was instrumental in making that
happen because she believed that he was
actually going to make
kuruga a much better place she didn't
believe that he was going to do the
things like
wiping out anybody who disagreed with
him or whatever now again
this is just the nature of just kind of
cleansing descent right
you can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs and if the people
who are dissenting against you
are the ones who want to keep things in
a state of chaos then they got gotta go
right that's just the way it is the the
americans did it to the british
that's just the way this kind of thing
goes right like whenever you're inciting
rebellion
and you're overthrowing an existing
government and replacing it with one
that's better
there are always going to be people out
there who were like no we want things to
stay the same
the people who are largely against what
you're doing will largely be the ones
who are in favor of keeping things the
same right
we want chaos we want political discord
we don't want things to get better under
your rule
we want things to stay bad and that's
why sinestro was just like they all
gotta go like literally killing them off
and getting rid of them but arsenal took
this as a personal affront
because she believed she had been used
in order to make that happen and the
reality is that she was
right she really was used in a lot of
ways but in the end the ends justified
the means
at least it seemed like it did until
basically sinestro were just kind of
cast down right and everything popped
off
and the sinestro court conquered the
entirety of the world and so what goes
on
is that while this kind of
conversation's happening between arsona
and uh and sinestro
how jordan's kind of listening in and
how jordan kind of talks to her while
senescer was trying to at least
explain himself to everybody how jordan
chimes in and says look you made my ring
right and sedesha was like yeah
and so he's like make more right i mean
they're not going to be nearly as
powerful
they're not going to last all that long
but in the end make more rings because
even if these rings only last
five to ten minutes like simestro says
they will it'll be five to ten minutes
longer they can survive
and you can do a lot of damage in five
to ten minutes
when you're a green lantern you can you
can you can take out a lot of people in
five to ten minutes
and so ultimately he fashions like 100
rings and then they just kind of go out
and they end up you know kind of bonding
to all these different people here
and then they initially kind of go to
take the revenge on sinestro but the
whole point of sinestro and really what
how jordan says is look guys
i get you got your beef with sinestro so
do i but understand
it's the only way for us to get out of
here so either you can deplete this
ring's charge by killing sinestro
and then die yourself at the hands of
the cenestro corps
or you can ally yourself with a guy that
you don't necessarily like
and we can all get out of here we can
live and we can get rid of the sinestro
core and
you can go back to doing whatever it is
that you want to do and so ultimately
they side with sinestro
at the same time he summons his green
lantern of course comes flying directly
to him
and then in turn he tells everybody
there no fear right do not
experience fear in any form or fashion
conquer it if you do
you'll empower the sinestro corps and
there's no possible way that you'll
survive
all this right and so how jordan pops
back up sanestro pops back up
all these people with rings start
popping back up the problem is the rings
start to vanish right the rings start to
disappear
and that when that happens thousand
estro and hal jordan
immediately line for the the central
power battery because
the reality is that all these folks here
are sona and all them i wouldn't go as
far as to say that they're cannon fodder
but there is good ass right i mean the
rings weren't going to last all that
long but the hope is that sinestro and
how jordan could get to the central
power battery
and basically shut it down before
everything else goes on
and they do right as soon as it gets to
the central power battery and literally
sinestro uses his lantern
because he had to be the one to be in
there instead of hal jordan it basically
shuts down
everybody who has a sinestro core ring
and kind of puts them puts them into a
sort of coma
and they won't wake back up until
sinestro allows them to right until he
turns the central power battery back on
and so that's one of those things
because what this does is it temporarily
removes the sinestro court from the
green lantern mythos kind of
jeff johnson company really doug mink
just kind of clearing all these
different things out right and kind of
making way
for what's going on the other part of
this is that sinestro basically grabs
the central power battery of the
sinestro core
gathers up everybody who is a member of
the core and then just kind of takes off
and you know with the intention of just
kind of locking them up or
taking them to other places and then of
course how jordan is teleported back to
earth
and that's kind of the funny thing is
he's like okay i've got my ring but i
don't have a lantern
i have no way of charging this thing so
at this point it's just a little
fashion piece right like hey y'all
ballin
with a green ring and like that's it
right so there is a kind of bit of
amends that goes on between him and
carol fares like hey like we're gonna
you know
we'll try to make it work and you know
we'll try to we'll knock boots for a
little while we'll kind of see where
things go
but the big takeaway from this is that
sinestro does return to owa
he hands over the sinestro port and
that's what the guardians of the
universe were looking for
they kind of figured as soon as they
made sinestro a green lantern the first
thing he would do is he would be lined
to kuruguru back home
and then as soon as he got there the
guardians knew he would realize the
sinestro chord conquered his world and
that in doing that
he would basically round up the
cenestral core really out of pride or
anger more than anything else
and then hand them over to the guardians
and clear the path and so much like how
jordan being out of the picture or at
least suspected to be out of the picture
the sinestro corps is as well which
really makes things easy for the
guardians plans because what they intend
to do
is actually wake up the first lantern
and the first lantern
will lead the third army which will
replace the green lantern corps and if
any of you guys know anything about the
first lantern you know
that guy is a monster but with that
being said we're going to bring this to
an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace